- It sounds conspiratorial.
But the first thing
you have to know
to understand is
build back better.
When I first heard that I
didn't realize what it was
and it was Joe Biden's
slogan to be elected.
And I thought who came up
with build back better.
That is the worst
slogan I've ever heard.
And it's because it was not,
that's not its
original language.
Now they're using build
back better in for the prime
minister of the UK,
prime minister of Japan.
They're using it in France.
They're using it in Canada.
It is the slogan
of the great reset.
(suspenseful music)
- I'm Dave Rubin in joining
me today is the host
of the Glenn Beck
program and the author
of The Great Reset:
Joe Biden and the Rise
of 21st Century Fascism.
Glenn Beck, welcome back
to the Rubin Report.
- Thank you very much,
Dave, how are you?
- I'm just fine. my friend,
you have recouped from COVID,
people were, you know,
celebrating your demise.
- I know, everybody was.
- Very excited.
- I know, I was
on the Levin show
and he said, how you feeling?
And I said, other than
having COVID in my
and the country being
destroyed, I'm good.
And he was like, wait,
do you have COVID?
And I'm like, yeah, no big deal.
It's going into my lungs
now, which it always does.
And I wasn't free.
I kept saying, I'm
not freaked out,
I'm not freaked out, it's
big deal, it's no big deal.
Oh my gosh, the world
was like set on fire.
Glenn Beck has COVID.
He should die.
It was bizarre.
- Glen, why is it?
Maybe you can explain this to me
You know a bit about
my political evolution.
Why is it that every time
one of my friends get COVID
you, Dennis Prager,
people want them to die.
Why is that?
You guys are good people
as far as I'm concerned.
Am I missing something Glenn?
- I think because the,
and it's happening
to the right too.
We are being dehumanized.
So we're not real people.
And because of
our point of view,
they're already talking about,
you know, no medical care.
We shouldn't be in society.
I mean, it's exactly what
happened in the 1930's,
in other places.
It just happens to be that it's
the political point of view
now that's not acceptable.
And what's scary is
57% of Democrats say,
it's 48% I think that say you
shouldn't have your children
if you won't get
them vaccinated.
And 57% say, maybe we
should put you in a camp.
That's terrifying, terrifying.
- So that kinda is what the
book is about to some extent.
Because it's about
that there has been
a move on all of
us and our freedoms
for quite some time.
I wanna show the
cover again here.
We'll put up a
proper image as well,
because it's a scary cover,
these faces, these are,
these are three scary people,
which one of these people,
it's Soros for me, for sure.
Our of Klaus Schwab,
Soros and Biden.
When you see immediately
seems like the scariest one,
like you wouldn't wanna
see him in a dark alley.
- Yeah, no, I think he, I mean,
he looks and more
and more every day,
like the emperor from Star Wars.
- Yeah, he looks
like Palpatine, yeah.
- Yeah, so I think the
scariest to me is Soros.
He has believe it or not
kind of the least to do
with the actual
verbiage in the book,
but he is the guy who started
the WEF with Klaus Schwab.
Klaus is the guy who
is really pushing it.
But without Soros, there
wouldn't be a place to push it.
And without Soros, it
wouldn't be being pushed.
He is a huge force.
The other one is Joe Biden,
who has bought into this 100%
and is on the road to
transform not just America,
but the entire Western world
in ways that will affect
your life, that you
can't even imagine yet.
When you get to the
end of the book,
you'll realize everything
is about to change.
How I eat, how I dress, what
I say, how I pick my job.
Do I get to pick my job?
My kids in school, they're
gonna be fast tracked.
Will they get to pick
their own career?
Everything is changing.
- So when you say this,
you obviously are talking
about the great reset.
- Yes.
- Which was a phrase
that if we were to utter
say a year ago,
people would say you were
a conspiracy theorist,
but as everyone knows,
yesterday's conspiracy theorist
is now today's truthteller.
You've been warning about sort
of all of this stuff forever.
I think the first
time that we sat down,
which is probably about
five years ago now, I said,
I used to watch you on Fox.
You'd have the board behind you
and you'd be scribbling all
this stuff and running across
the room and the whole thing.
And I'd be going,
this guy is half genius,
half crazy, half entertainer.
And I know that
that's three halves,
but there was just a lot there.
But you have,
you really have been sort
of tracking all of this
from the financial system,
to the political system
and everything else.
So I guess, where did
you like, in retrospect,
I suppose, looking back now,
do you see a moment when
you first started putting
the pieces together
for some of this stuff?
- Yeah, so I started,
first started putting
the pieces together
and I didn't know what
I was dealing with
up until about a
year and a half ago.
I mean, I thought we were
dealing with socialists
and we're not,
the socialists are being used.
Anybody who's a Marxist,
boy, are you gonna be pissed
when they finally show up.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- That is cover to hide
what's really going on.
And I didn't figure
that one out,
but I do remember sitting
in my studio in Radio City
and I was getting
ready to do a show
and there was a little article.
I mean, it was
literally, I mean,
just a few paragraphs in the
Wall Street Journal buried.
And it was about one of the
Congressmen introducing,
and then them passing this
bill that you could not
take your money out of the
United States with you.
And I thought, hmm, somebody
knows something is coming.
Somebody knows, I mean,
we've never had a problem
with exodus of money.
What is that?
And that's when I first
started going, wait a minute,
what's going on?
And then I realized
that when they say
they wanna make the
world fair and equitable,
it was about 2007 or 2008
that I realized, well,
you can't do that.
You can't bring the
rest of the world
up to the United States
'cause we've tried
and it's getting better,
but it's not up.
It's not up to parities.
So the easy thing to do is
bring the United States down
to everybody else's level
and that's what we're doing.
- So let's talk about the
Joe Biden part in this.
'Cause I wanna talk about
sort of the machine behind it,
but let's just get to like
the parts that I think
are a little more easy for
people to understand first.
- Sure.
- On the Joe Biden part,
do you think Biden is fully
aware of what he is part of?
- Yeah.
- The sort of year,
you think he is?
That in this last year,
the level of destruction
that has been brought
across this country,
supply chain, inflation,
the whole shebang,
Afghanistan, everything, COVID.
- Yeah, I'm not sure he.
I'm not sure he understands
the impact, but he does.
He is fully aware and
committed to the direction.
I don't know how much
he sees of the wreckage,
but he is committed
to the direction.
And I say that because
his first speech
in front of Congress,
remember he got in,
it was about a month later
and it was kind of a
State of the Union thing.
And if you knew what
you were looking for,
it was terrifying, terrifying.
He started when he
came in and remember
they were all sitting
like six feet apart
and so not everybody was there.
And he said, you are the ones.
And I remember
thinking he's at first,
he's looking at the camera and
talking to us and he's like,
you are the ones.
And then he started pointing
and looking at all the people
in Congress that
have saved the world.
And you are the ones here
that made things happen.
He wasn't talking to
the American people.
He was talking to the
elites in that room.
The next thing he said,
and he said it twice,
plus, he briefed
the news anchors
prior to the speech on what
he was going to talk about in
the real problem in America.
And he said it
twice in the speech.
He said, you know,
we have to decide whether
our system of government
can compete with these new
authoritarian governments
like China and the
jury's still out.
Well, he said before the speech
that he's still
betting on America,
but eh, I don't know
if it's gonna survive.
It has to dramatically change.
So they are,
what they've put
together literally
is the definition of fascism.
Forget about the Jackboots,
forget out what you
think that means.
Look at the real definition,
that is a public
private partnership,
with private businesses.
And if you're in the party or
you're doing what the party
wants you to do, you're fine.
The minute you're
not, you're out,
whether that is, you know,
a slave camp or you're
just out kicking rocks,
that's what's happening in China
and China is the model here.
- Do you think that
basically the last 20 years
of U.S. diplomacy with China,
we thought that we
could get them a little,
to be a little more like us.
And in fact, it
actually just worked out
the other way that we just
didn't have the wherewithal
to stand for American values
and fight for the good stuff
that we've been doing here
for 200 plus years?
- I think that changed
maybe around Clinton.
And I include the Republicans
in this thinking as well.
I think in the
90's at some point
the business people
and the government saw,
okay, this is communism light.
This isn't the Jackbooted
thugs, even though it was,
and they can move quickly and
they can do things quickly
and they can just direct,
you know, policies and hey,
we're gonna be
number one in cars,
so let's focus on cars
and they loved that.
And I remember in the
90's hearing from very big
business people, you know,
China is just a different
place and it's very exciting
and it is quote, it
is the new model.
And I remember back
in the 90's going,
well, I don't want
China to be our model.
That's not what we are.
And the big business and
government just started working
hand in hand over
the last 20 years.
And moving towards
that and saying,
it's much better 'cause
we can get things done.
- So the argument basically
that you're laying
out in the book
is that through the World
Economic Forum, Klaus Schwab,
then some of these
NGO's and all the stuff
that Soros is funding
and then with the president
of the United States,
that they're are all
sort of together working
to bring this here.
I mean, so is it here?
I mean, is it fully here?
- Oh, it is here.
- We're just in it now.
- We're in it, we are living
the very beginnings of it.
It is here, it's not
too late to change it.
But Dave, what's so frustrating
about the sales of the book,
the book sold out on day one.
The next printing I can get
is I think they come out
at the end of February.
Those I believe
are all sold out.
We're on our third printing,
which will come out in March.
People have to read this now.
Time is of the essence.
It is so frustrating.
We are in it and it
sounds conspiratorial.
But the first thing
you have to know to,
to understand is
build back better.
When I first heard that I
didn't realize what it was
and it was Joe Biden's
slogan to be elected.
And I thought who came up
with build back better?
That is the worst
slogan I've ever heard.
And it it's because it was not,
that's not its
original language.
Now they're using build
back better in for the prime
minister of the UK,
prime minister of Japan.
They're using it in France.
They're using it in Canada.
It is the slogan
of the great reset.
When we went into COVID,
if you remember right,
and I was looking for it,
so maybe you won't remember,
they all said a new normal.
We're gonna go back
to a new normal.
Well, I knew what they
were talking about
because before they
said new normal,
several said the great reset.
And that's what they
have been sharing
and moving us towards
is this great reset.
So A, it's not a conspiracy
and it's almost when
you read the book,
it is almost the Rosetta
stone for the news.
You will understand why was
Home Depot allowed to stay open?
But my local hardware
store couldn't?
Why is it I can go
to a restaurant,
especially a chain restaurant,
I can sit down and as
soon as I sit down,
I can take off my mask.
But when I go on an
airplane, I'm seated,
but I have to use
the mask in between.
And that air filtering
system is far superior
than any restaurant
I've ever been in.
- Glenn science, I thought
it was 'cause of science.
- Yes.
- Yeah, no, it's
not about science.
It's all about control.
- My notes are for
definitely confused here.
- Yeah.
So, okay, so it's about control,
we're in the beginnings of it.
Do you see any markers that
show us the way out of this?
So for example, as we're
taping this right now,
there is a massive,
probably the biggest
world wide convoy of trucks
happening in Canada right now
in protest of these
mandates, of these lockdowns,
which is directly connected
obviously to everything else
you're talking about here,
that's pretty good, right?
That's pretty good.
- That's great.
And it is those things
that will stop it.
But what has to be stopped,
the most important
thing that cannot
get its roots any deeper,
if you are an investor of
401K and let's say you have
your 401k through, you
know, I don't know,
JP Morgan or whatever,
I want you to go to
your website and see,
look for ESG scores.
And I think it's Charles
Schwab that has the ESG score
for your account.
And when I've talked about this,
I think it was Bank
of America or City,
one of the banks called
and said, no, no, no,
that's not what ESG's are about.
We're never gonna
use 'em for people.
And I said, then why
is your subsidiary
using on my account?
Why do I have an ESG score?
And they said, well,
that's because we are doing
that because a lot of people
really care about social
justice and environment
and governance of the boards.
And so we're just
helping them know
who they're investing in.
And I said, you're
so full of crap.
You can't see through the brown
in your eyes for
the love of Pete.
Now they are clear on this.
ESG has to be stopped right now
because that is the control of
your business, of your money,
of absolutely
everything in your life.
It is your social credit score.
And it is starting at the
bank level for businesses,
all of the big businesses,
they're all in on ESG.
Warning, that is
the fascistic system
that will trickle down to you.
- And Glenn call me crazy,
but do you think they might
be able to link something
like an ESG score or
perhaps a vaccine passport?
Is that something a
crazy person might say?
- That's why the passport
on the vaccine passport
is so important.
You know, I was talking
to one of those truckers
that was in Canada
and he had to deliver
something to the United States.
He has to have the app on
his phone that he shows.
And you know, you
just scan the QR.
He got to the border for
the Canadian crossing.
He went to United States
and then turned around
after he dropped his load
and he was coming
back into Canada.
He had his phone on the QR code
and he was ready to
put it out the window
and to show it to the guy.
He rolls the window down,
he starts moving towards and
guy goes, no, I got that.
You're okay, go ahead.
And he said, wait a minute,
aren't you supposed
to scan this?
And he said, no.
And I don't remember the
distance, but it was like,
you know, when you're
within a quarter of a mile,
all of that is
transmitted to us.
We know exactly who
you are, holy cow.
And by the way, if you
think this is nuts,
it has gotten so bad in China
that you cannot leave your
house without your phone.
If you do, the facial
recognition finds you,
they send the police
out to you to say,
go back to your house
and get your phone.
It is such a part of life now.
You've heard the Amber
Alert that (beep).
That's that happens when you
start to approach someone
who has a low credit score.
If you have a low
social credit score
everybody's phone
around that person,
warns them don't get any closer
or it'll affect your score.
This stuff with Joe Rogan is
not about COVID, it's not.
It's about silencing
any kind of dissent.
And if they win with
Rogan, we are gone.
We're gone.
- So we covered that on
my show this morning.
I said it is the
biggest cultural
and political story of the day.
- It is.
- And I mean, by the day, I
don't mean literally today.
I mean, right now it
is the biggest thing,
because it's a marker
for everything.
Do you think Rogan's
gonna be able
to stand up to this thing?
Because you know, he gave
a pretty good pushback,
but they are Spotify now
is putting disclaimers
in front of his videos,
which he said he welcomed.
So do you think, do you think,
he can fight this thing?
- Here's the thing.
I don't know, I mean I
think you know Rogan.
- Yeah.
- I don't Joe,
but he seems like a guy
who really knows who he is.
- Yeah.
- And the problem he has,
and you know this, Dave,
we've talked about this.
If you don't have
your own platform
and even with your own platform,
Amazon can cut you off.
The banks can cut you off.
If you don't have your
own platform, where
are you gonna go?
He just traded YouTube,
which would've kicked him
off by now, traded YouTube
and all those views and easy
access without a paywall,
he traded that to
go over to Spotify.
He was smart enough to make sure
that they're paying him, money
doesn't talk, it screams,
a hundred million
dollars screams to him,
but it also screams to Spotify.
You don't flush that
down the toilet.
Can he make some
adjustments to his show?
Yeah, he shouldn't.
We should all be outraged
that the federal government,
the only reason why
Spotify did anything,
they don't care about Joni
Mitchell for the love of,
nobody cares, Joni
Mitchell's family
doesn't care about
Joni Mitchell.
So it's not that, it's that
the surgeon general came out
and on advice from the
White House and said,
this is dangerous to
people and you know,
social media and Spotify, they
need to step up their game.
Well, that is the
very clear definition
of a violation of
the First Amendment.
There's the government
using their power
to coerce somebody
to do something.
I don't know Dave, if he
survives, I hope he does,
but this is, COVID
is only the pre-game,
financial is the real game.
And when our economy
starts to collapse,
the great reset people
back in December
did nine or 10 day war game
on a financial collapse.
And the first
thing that they did
was they had to
silence the people
who were saying anything
other than the official truth.
And what they were
saying was these people
are going to get the
entire financial system
globally to collapse.
You've got to shut them up.
And those people were saying,
I don't think I believe the
bank on this, this or this,
or maybe you get your
money out of the bank
because bank
holidays are coming.
All of those things are
true as they war gamed,
but they will
silence us quickly.
- The move that the
surgeon general made,
that comment that he
made, that you know,
that the big tech companies,
they should look into
this sort of thing,
is very consistent with what
this administration did.
I'm sure you saw the video.
I'm sure you covered it.
When Jen Psaki a
couple months back.
Yeah, we flag
things for Facebook.
We flag, I mean, have they just,
have they just figured out
a way around the First
Amendment at this point, I mean,
does the First Amendment.
- No, because that is,
what they just did is
against the First Amendment.
- Well, it's not a law.
In other words,
have they just has figured
out the wink and it works
that you don't need
to pass a law, yeah.
- So, that is the thing
about the great reset,
everyone is a stakeholder
and it is a complete end run
around the constitution,
around all governments,
it is an amazing
thing, by the way,
he's still pushing his
build back better package.
Guess who else is
doing that right now?
England has a build
back better package.
Almost the same.
I think France does as well.
Germany has one as well.
And they're all
exactly the same.
It's just how open and honest
are you going to be on
what it's gonna cost?
We are saying that it's free.
I think Germany is saying, yeah,
we're gonna tax
the snot outta ya.
- So does the U.S.
because of the way we're
set up different states.
And as you know, I
was pretty damn close
to moving to Texas.
- I know.
- We talked about
it at your house.
I mean, I was pretty damn
close, Cannis tried to sell me
on Nashville, but all right.
I settled here in Florida
and I gotta tell you, man,
it's freaking fantastic.
- I know.
- Do you think that
our Federalist system
is at least set up to
fight this thing better?
Where in places like Britain
and France that you mentioned,
they don't have
that local control.
- Yes.
- So we are, we are
in the best position.
Remember this is not
an American thing.
This is all of
the Western world.
And we are in the best position.
Unfortunately, we are taking
the lead on a lot of it.
And that's why every step you
take towards silencing voices
or giving the
government more power,
the worst this becomes
because there will be a,
another emergency that they
will use to finally grab
that rope and pull a
TOT around our necks.
But our Federalist system works.
It's really heartening to
see two states, one state,
I think it was,
was it Nebraska that
passed their article five
constitutional convention.
Yeah.
And then there was another
state that was doing it
this weekend as well.
- We gotta keep pushing on that.
- It has to happen.
Our states have to separate
themselves from the federal
government on certain issues.
You cannot come in a
and tell us what to do.
The local and state is the
only thing that will stop this.
There are three states.
I talked to 'em,
I don't know, a week
after the book came out.
And I think it was
the Treasury Secretary
of West Virginia.
It is also Texas and New
Hampshire that are putting laws
in right now because
of the great reset
to ban all banks from
using ESG scores.
Because that they're saying
that that's the way they're
gonna make all their
financial decisions.
Well, no, that has nothing
to do with credit scores
that has everything
to do with politics.
And they're banning them,
if we could get half
the states to ban ESG's
with financial institutions,
you'd be a long way down
that Federalist road
that would stop this.
- So what can we do
individually besides the people
that should probably
pick up and go,
if you live in California
and you live in New York,
the places that are
gonna be the epicenters
for this nonsense, I
mean, what can people do?
Like, would you recommend people
actually take their money outta
Chase and put it in the
local federal credit union
in their city?
I mean, is that that's
probably a small step.
- 100%, that's a big step
because if all of our
audiences did that,
it would shake the
financial markets.
They would be like,
wait a minute, wait a
minute, wait a minute.
How much money have you lost?
Because that's the money
that they are using.
And by the way, after
September, I'm sorry,
after '08 and the
banking collapse,
the laws were changed.
The money you have in
your checking and savings,
you are the depositor
of last resort.
So you can't go get your money.
If they say, you know,
there's a banking crisis,
we need all the
money we can get,
you have zero
access to the money.
You are the last debtor
that they need to pay.
You're not the first.
So I'm not giving my money
to these big financial
institutions.
You go to your
local credit union,
make sure that everything is,
I can't remember the
acronym for the FDIC for.
- Right, there's a
separate one, yeah.
- A separate one.
But you make sure
that it's insured
and put everything there.
It's so critical that
we are not taking money,
our money, loaning money,
giving money to these banks
that are then spreading it all
over America and the news
that broke last week,
all over the world.
Instead, we must keep it local.
We have to strengthen
our local communities,
our local businesses.
So best way to do it.
And I would do it today.
Take your money,
and tell them why.
I'm not gonna be in a,
a bank that is involved
and has ESG scores.
I'm going to a local
credit union, do it today.
- So speaking of things
that you can do today,
we're all watching, you
know, the supply chain stuff.
And it took me, I moved
to Florida a month ago.
It took the truck literally
five weeks to get here
because the truck
with all my stuff
just came this week because
they can only get trucks
to drive one way,
because in a normal time,
trucks are going both
ways with stuff they can.
And they also can't
get drivers any more
and the price of gas went
up and the supply chain,
you can't get stuff to build out
in say a house or a studio
and everything else.
Do we just need to build a
parallel economy at every level.
And I mean, from banks
to a new Home Depot,
to just the whole damn thing,
we're gonna have to buy
our own candy shops.
- And you, you start
by putting your money
into a local bank and just
realize it's the George
Bailey savings and loan.
You know, it has to stay local.
They are Mr. Potter.
That is the best movie to
explain the great reset.
You know, he looks at
people just as, you know,
they're bums and they're
never gonna get anywhere.
So he'll take their money
and he'll build Potterville
and that is what
they're building
in the Western world
is Potterville.
Can I ask you one
question, Dave?
- Sure.
- What are you
doing with Bitcoin?
I put my money in Bitcoin
and I'm like, let it ride.
But now with the treasury,
the fed. the IMF,
they are gonna
kill these things.
What are you doing?
Are you leaving it in or
are you taking it out?
- Yeah, so I have a chunk
of Bitcoin. not a ton,
but I have several Bitcoin
and I'm just leaving it.
I've never touched any of it.
And I just wanted to sit
there and see what happens.
I actually was gonna ask
you in a few minutes about,
you know, Biden now wants
to regulate Bitcoin,
which is the whole purpose
of a decentralized coin,
a whole decent centralized
system is to not be regulated.
And you can see, obviously,
anyone watching
this can understand
why that would be separate.
That's the off ramp
for this insanity.
I think people have to have it.
You have to be able to
diversify because if they come
for you, if what you're
laying out here is right,
and by and large, I think it is.
It's like, you're gonna
need some other ways
to have commerce with people.
You're gonna be able, when
the shit hits the fan, I mean,
you're gonna need to be able
to trade goods and services
with people.
And that that's where
crypto comes in.
- So that's where
I go to, you know,
I live here in the
city in Dallas,
but if crap starts
to hit the fan,
I've got another house in a
very small farming community.
And that's where
I'm planning on,
on being with my
family and friends.
It's in this really small,
tight knit community.
And we are right now
working on, you know,
the farmer's market.
We are talking to each other,
hey, what do you have
in your tool shed
that can make things,
you know, what do you have?
And so we're not buying the
same things that we can share
if things really get bad,
that we can fix
everything that we need.
That's the kind of
stuff that I think
we really need to look at.
Are you in a community
of like-minded people
that will help each
other because Dave,
there's something else that
I touch on in the book.
What's so insidious about this,
is I have been talking
since probably 1995.
There is a new industrial
revolution that is coming.
That will be as profound as
the industrial revolution,
but it, when it starts, it will
happen in a 10 year period,
not a hundred years.
Well, we're there.
We are already, I think,
I think we're year two
in that industrial,
the fourth industrial
revolution.
And by 2030, 40% of jobs
are going to be gone.
Maybe there'll be some new
things, but probably not.
That's why we're
talking about, you know,
basic universal income
and everything else
because tech knows
what is coming and now,
so do our politicians.
The one that we are,
that everybody is pushing
us the opposite direction
that we have to
recognize, stop and go
the other way is empathy.
The only thing that AI
cannot duplicate is empathy.
If you are looking
to tell your kids,
what kind of job
are you gonna get?
You you'd be really wise to say,
forget about school or whatever.
If you wanna be a
nurse, go to school,
not a doctor, a nurse,
go to school and make sure you
focus everything on empathy,
because the AI is gonna tell you
everything that's going
on in that person.
You have to be the one that
is the face that comes in
and says, it's all right.
Everything is alright.
It's gonna be okay
because AI cannot do that.
That's where its hole is.
Also, if the world is
run by AI or people that,
you know, just think of
other people as sheep,
gosh, they are
missing all empathy.
And that's a pretty dark world.
- You know, it's interesting.
I actually heard you
talking about this,
this empathy with AI and the
robots and that even when they
show the, when you see the
robots that we have now,
they cannot show
true human emotion.
They do these things that
actually look completely
counter to human emotion,
when they try to
show human emotions.
And it looks more robotic
than you would think,
robotic would even look.
- So in, wait, hang on,
In animation, that's
called the, what is it?
The Erie valley or
the creepy valley.
- The uncanny valley.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And animation has found a way
where they're coming out
of the uncanny valley.
They don't think AI will ever
get out of the uncanny valley
because it is something really,
truly spiritual
human in the eyes.
And when you see
it, you know it,
and there's a lot of people
that you can talk to that just
don't have that, you know,
they might feel sorry for you,
but they're not those people
that have real empathy
and you know the difference
and AI will never be able
to compete with that.
- Is that the weird moment
that we're in that everything
you're describing here sounds
like a dystopian movie,
most likely or a book
that was originally
written by Philip K. Dick.
But I mean,
everything, you sound,
this sort of sounds
like Minority Report.
It sort of sounds
like Terminator.
It sort of sounds like I, Robot.
We're rushing, Matrix for sure,
that were rushing towards it.
We all have had
all the warnings.
The warning signs
are all behind us.
They were in books.
They were in movies,
they're in history,
they're in the Bible,
they're all there and
we're just rushing
and we're all going, oh,
you know, let's keep going,
'cause who's gonna stop us?
- Right, and we all
kind of know too.
- Yeah.
- We all feel something.
I don't care what
political stripe you are,
we all know something
is really not right.
This is not gonna
end well, we know it.
And you know, what's crazy is
in many ways the
liberals were right.
We were wrong.
We thought it would come,
as you know, some
communist Marxist thing.
Those guys are being used.
This is coming through
our corporations.
Every time I watch
a dystopian movie,
I roll my eyes when
they're like, oh,
I work for the corporation,
AKA the government.
And I'm like, oh, stop it.
That is what they're
right and how the left is,
I'm against big
pharmaceutical companies.
Really, except the right
now when it counts?
I mean, it's crazy.
They knew all this stuff.
We mocked them.
And now we're standing
where they were going, guys,
you were right.
I mean, can't you see this?
- But you gotta kind
of admire, it right?
Like not what it's doing,
but the trick that it
pulled right there,
you gotta admire that, that
these people you've got,
as you're saying,
they're the pawns,
these communists and socialists
and all these people,
they're the pawns and
the foot soldiers.
And they think that
they're against the power
while they literally are
for all the corporations.
They're for all
of the messaging.
I walk into target yesterday
to buy some cleaning supplies
and there's a massive Black
Lives Matter section there.
And it's like, you're
fighting the power?
Really?
With that shirt and sweatshirt
and pants and shoes?
- I think in a
hundred years, Dave,
this is going to be studied
in every government program
that is, you know,
trying to teach about
history and government
and behavioral science.
This is the time that
the world will look back.
I think we are going to be
studied for a thousand years,
especially if we defeat it,
no nation has ever defeated
anything like this.
I think we could be the
exception to that rule,
but only if we all wake up,
don't go down the
road of conspiracies,
just get the actual facts.
'Cause they're worse than
anybody that could come up
with conspiracies online.
These are true.
And if you just do that,
remain calm, work on empathy,
don't play into their
hands, we beat them.
And here's why I know this.
Have you ever seen the
government ever work this hard
to silence people and
keep them in line?
I've never seen it.
If they thought we were sheep,
if they thought we couldn't
stop it, they wouldn't care.
They wouldn't do any of this.
But they are working
over overtime.
And they're talking now probably
about at least 50%
of the country.
Remember to change things,
the tipping point is
like 19% or two 20%.
They're talking about
half of the nation.
That's pretty significant
and they know it.
- Have you in all the time
you've been talking about this
and taken, you know,
dozens of callers every day
on your radio show
and everything else.
Have you learned anything
about the type of person,
the makeup of the person or
the belief system of the person
that is willing to
go into the fire
and be the guy in
their social circle
that's gonna talk about
this stuff and change people
and everything else.
'Cause I get some version
of this question a lot.
People want, they kind
of get it, but you know,
they've got their job.
They kind of get it,
but they've got their family.
They, they don't
wanna really get in.
But now I think you're right.
We are getting to this
odd, critical mess.
I mean, when you know,
you've pushed Canadians to do
what they're doing up there,
you know something's wrong.
- Canadians don't, they never,
they're never pissed off
about anything, anything ever.
- So do you think is it?
What do you think it is that,
that we can do to help
ignite that thing in people,
not just know about the stuff,
but that other thing,
the other thing.
- So I think the easiest
line to cross, I mean,
Nancy Pelosi, all these
things is for the children.
It's for the children.
So it's not about the
children with them.
It is about the
children with individual
families and moms and dads.
That's why you saw the
pushback coming at school.
That's why you saw,
I mean I have friends who
are very liberal thought,
they could never have
voted for anybody
but Joe Biden that are
really smoked right now.
And the tipping point was wait,
you wanna vaccinate my
little, my little ones?
Are you kidding me?
Never.
It is our children
that speak to us
that make us much more brave.
But I think it's
just connecting.
We have to connect
enough people.
The week I released the book,
all I kept hearing in my head
was the eyes of the world
are upon you.
That's what FD, sorry,
that's what Dwight Eisenhower
said on the day of
D-Day to the troops,
the eyes of the
world are upon you.
And what you do today will
decide the freedom of men
and women all over the world.
We need to get to a place
to where people understand
this is our World War II.
This is our opportunity.
Is it going to be lost
in this generation?
And if they really
truly understand that,
then they'll be
courageous because people
with children don't want,
my kids, I have them in thirties
and I have them in teenagers
and the older ones have
come to me and went, so dad,
what is life going to
be like now for my kids?
And my answer is it's
yet to be decided.
If we do all that we're
supposed to do, it will be fine.
We're gonna go through
really difficult times,
but we make it out
on the other end.
If we don't, if
we don't stand up,
Dave, this is all of the
technology that Hitler wanted.
I mean, it it's, you
know, the what's his name?
Yuval Noah Harari.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- You know him?
- [Dave Yeah.
- So in his book
he talks about that
the age of free will is over.
And he says that's right now,
that you don't really
make the decisions
that you think you make
because you're so influenced
by what you see.
And it starts with, oh,
you're finished with that book.
You'd like this one.
And so we're losing our decision
making free will ability.
We have to exercise that.
We have to exercise courage
in the smallest ways.
'Cause if you're not, if
you are not building courage
now it is only gonna get harder
and you won't be able
to deadlift that weight.
- You know, I don't know
that I've ever connected
this directly before,
but you know, I do my off
the grid August thing,
which you've welcomed
me back on before.
but I do always feel
more brave after.
Every, the five year, the
five years that I've done it,
I feel, I always expected
to feel clear minded,
but I always feel that I
have this renewed sense
of passion to get right back in
and keep fighting for the
things that I believe in.
- Because the algorithms
haven't been telling you
every day, all day,
you're too small.
You're too small.
- You think there's
something there,
there might be something there.
- I think so.
- So, in our last
couple of minutes,
not to connect this
back to politics purely,
'cause I think we're
talking about something
that's bigger than politics,
but you and I did not vote for
Trump the first time around.
We both did the
second time around.
If he had been president now,
if he had won that
last election,
was that the wall
that we needed?
No pun intended with Trump.
I mean, was that the thing?
And he was the thing that was
gonna at least temporarily
stop it or the dam or
something like that.
- So I truly believe
I have no evidence
to back this up other than
all of the corporations banded
together to stop him,
which was unusual.
I am convinced that
this is the real reason
why they stopped him.
It wasn't about anything else
except he's America First.
So we can't get him
on this bandwagon.
The minute he canceled
the Paris Accords,
which was not about
global warming,
it is about ESG and
the financial system.
That's all it's about,
is the banking system.
When he canceled that
they realized, we're done.
If he doesn't, if he
stays in and they,
they had to destroy him.
I don't know because he, I
think he kicks down walls.
He's got a good gut on him
and he kicks down walls.
Not necessarily knowing
what's behind it,
but that's not good over there.
My gut tells me these people
over here are doing no good.
If he knows and he's willing
to stand up against it,
which I think he would be,
he would be very,
very, very good.
I'm not sure he fully
understands what he exposed yet.
- Even after your
recent sitdown with him,
do you think he didn't get it?
And not that you fully well
went into all of this, but.
- I said to him
and I've asked him,
'cause I just talked
to him again on Friday.
And I asked him
the same question,
Mr. President, you have
to clear out every agency,
you've gotta fire all of them.
And he said, I know.
One thing he said was I,
I can't do it with
the GOP that I have
because it will take an
act of Congress and Senate.
He can't do it with
Mitch McConnell.
They just won't do it.
He needs help in Congress
and in the Senate
to be able to clean
out the viper's nest.
I had a Congressman
who's very low key.
Makes Mike Lee look a
little hyper at times,
who said to me on Friday,
Glenn the FBI is the KGB.
And I'm like, I'm
sorry, excuse me.
And he said,
it is the KGB and we all
in Washington know it
and no one's doing
anything about it.
And they have to be cleaned out.
Trump, I asked this Friday,
are you working with
a council of people?
Are you doing anything
to draw up a naughty
and nice list and figure out
what you're gonna do, 'cause
you only have four years
if you run and win, four
years, that's not enough.
And this is gonna be, this will
be a death match to do this.
I think he's the
only guy who would,
but I don't know if he
will or understands it yet.
- Glenn, I have only one
more question for you,
which is fairly obvious
after this conversation,
can I come to this
special unknown place
and have a small parcel of land?
Listen, you know,
I had chickens.
I know how to, I know how
to deal with the coup.
I know how to clean.
I've gotten pretty good at
a couple other handy things
in a new house here.
And I, you know,
and I'm pretty decent
for conversation.
- As long as you just make sure
you always say I'm from
Florida you can come.
- I'm gonna literally
have to erase
the first 35 years of
my life, that's fine.
- I've never lived
to California,
what are you talking about?
- Please.
- It's another Dave Rubin
who looks just like me.
- Glenn, it's always an honor
talking to you and I'm glad
to be in the fight with you
and hope to see you in
the free state of Texas
or in the free state of Florida.
- I think I'm coming to
Florida in a couple of weeks,
so I'll have to see you then.
- We'll fire up the grill.
See you soon.
- God bless.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics, watch our
full episode playlist,
right over here, and to get
notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.